hello everybody welcome to another
Sunday morning science broadcast today
we're going to talk more about memes we
talked about it quite a bit last week
but there's been a lot of confusion I've
seen in the comments and I just spoke
yesterday with youtuber Adam friended
and he put up I haven't seen it yet but
he put up our our discussion yesterday
and there was a there's a lot of
confusion about memes how it is it memes
evolve
do they really evolve the conversation
is actually kind of frustrating because
I find this topic actually really simple
to understand but a lot of people don't
and it's maybe it's because I've been
I've been reading about this stuff and
kind of following it for it's probably
been 10 years or so and it's it's uh I'm
excited to see what kind of questions
you guys have about memes in the
comments today and yeah let's just dig
in so I've got a presentation as usual
so let me share my screen hopefully you
can see that there so what exactly is a
meme and I want to talk about what what
exactly memes are and why does it matter
like why should we care you know the the
field of mimetics
got going in the 90s and then it kind of
died out why is it that I think that we
should bring this back and I think this
is really important
just a reminder for those who did maybe
didn't see last week's there was a
debate recently between Richard Dawkins
and Brett Weinstein about religion is
religion miles about a bunch of
different things but one of the things I
talk about is is religion a an
adaptation that helps people survive and
reproduce or is it a virus because
Dawkins always talks often talks about
religion as being a virus of the mind
and if you really look at how memes work
you know religion is a collection of
memes I'm getting ahead of myself
let's just talk about what a meme is so
a meme is a unit of cultural
transmission or a unit of imitation and
you've probably heard about internet
memes but the concept is actually much
older than internet memes
it comes from Dawkins book The Selfish
Gene this is how he defines it a unit of
cultural transmission or a unit of
imitation so a famous example is the
idea of a wheel if your walk if you
don't know what a wheel is and you're
walking down the street you're walking
down I guess you wouldn't have a street
if there wasn't wheels you're walking
down the pathway in your village and you
see somebody rolling something heavy on
top of a wheel
Wow you see it happening and you
immediately want to imitate that next
time you have something heavy to move
and so the the invention of a wheel the
idea of a wheel is really easy to
transmit lots of different cultural lots
of different ideas any any idea that we
might have can be transmitted if if I
think that you know wearing a shirt with
the top button undone is a good idea I
can spread that and tell other people
hey if you you feel like you're your
button-up shirts a little bit stuffy
just undo the top button and you're fine
so these are all types of any idea that
you might have is considered a meme and
memes are replicators because ideas can
be shared and when an idea is shared it
gets copied into someone else's mind and
so a meme is a replicator in the mind Oh
sphere just like a gene as a replicator
in the biosphere so there is a bunch of
humans with minds and there's only so
much space in these minds there's
limited space and these memes can
replicate to fill that space so a meme
is a genuine replicator
should be thought of as a virus or a
parasite well first of all let's just
talk about what evolution is evolution
is replication plus modification plus
selection when we have those three
things we have adaptive evolution and
this is basically the equation that
Darwin gave us explained that animals
and plants can evolve because of descent
with modification replication and with
modification acted upon by selection and
he focused most of his attention on
natural selection but of course there's
sexual selection and artificial
selection and so on
so genes really evolve because they are
replicators and they are capable of
modification mutation and they undergo
selection memes are also genuine
evolving entities because memes really
do replicate from one brain to another
they do so with slight modifications
when those modifications happen they're
then passed down let me try and give you
an example of this a lot of people like
to eat potatoes right and a lot of
people like to peel their potatoes
before eating them and some people might
use a potato peeler some people might
use a knife and depending on what you
saw when you were a child you were going
to do the same so if you go to different
families and watch them preparing
potatoes you'll notice that they peel
their potatoes in different ways and
this is because of the memes that have
been duplicating in these different
little cultural groups and family lines
there are actually some people that
won't peel their potatoes they want to
eat their potatoes with the skin on so
that's a different mean and that meme
the you should eat potatoes with skin on
them is in direct conflict with the meme
you should peel potatoes before eating
them those two memes cannot exist in the
same space so they are actually
competing with each other just like
genes the blue-eyed genes that code for
blue eyes are
petition with the genes that code for
brown eyes within a population the memes
that tell us to peel our potatoes are in
direct competition with the memes that
tell us not to peel our potatoes so they
really do evolve they really do compete
for existence in the mind of fear here's
an example of two competing memes the
earth is 6000 years old versus the other
meme the earth is 4.5 billion years old
and what we've found when studying
genetics is that certain genes do really
well not on their own but they do really
well with others other by cooperating
with other genes and it turns out that
the same is true for memes so whether or
not you're going to accept this first
meme or this second meme here if you
hear them both is going to depend on a
whole bunch of other memes that you
already have in your head and here's
just a short example a quick example of
some memes that might make it easier for
you to accept the 6,000 year old one the
Bible is the literal word of God the
Bible is infallible the earth is 6,000
years old if you have those first two
memes it makes it very likely that
you're going to accept that that third
meme and especially you're going to
accept that over the conflicting meme
the earth is 4.5 billion years old the
if you happen to possess the other memes
we can learn about reality through
careful observation and scientific
consensus is generally trustworthy then
when you hear that the earth is 4.5
billion years old you are more likely to
accept that mean instead of the the
earth as 6,000 years old me because of
course scientific consensus is from
multiple fields of research that the
earth is billions of years old
not thousands of years old so this is
how meme memes are competing in the mind
of sphere memes team up and work
cooperate with other memes to be more
sticky and to replicate more efficiently
and all of this happens just naturally
it's because of descent with
modification acted upon by selection
these things happen naturally now of
course humans can get together and try
and engineer memes and try an engineer
memes that they think will be sticky
marketing teams do this and so on but
for the most part memes evolve on their
own within the mind of sphere and
oftentimes they create extremely
complicated super structures such as
religions such as economic systems
cultural norms oral views that we just
we inherit these worldviews we inherit
these mimetic systems and we don't
really know how they work they it really
takes careful studying to understand how
they work where they come from how
different memes are cooperating with
each other and so on it's it's a
complicated serious business if you
actually want to dig into it and try and
figure this stuff out it's not simple
it's not super straightforward we do
things all the time and we don't know
why and a lot of times not always but a
lot of times our behaviors are being
dictated by the memes that we happen to
have inherited or accepted into our
minds now one of the things that Adam
was talking about yesterday in our
conversation is that there are some
ideas that he thinks are just evolved
ideas and I think he's right when we are
born we are not blank slates there are
some basic programs that are running in
our brains one for a baby is you know
right the things that we call instincts
are these basic programs and so one of
those would be emulate your parents copy
your parents that's that's something
that the babies and small children have
in their minds they pretty much trust
their parents they'll obey they'll
believe what their parents say they'll
try to emulate their parents do what
their parents do and then you have you
have during puberty that seems to get
uprooted instinctually to find people
who are successful
in your community and emulate them copy
their behavior and so there's a little
bit of a switch in the instinctual
program as we go through puberty and
that kind that makes kids rebel from
there against their parents and so on
and causes all sorts of you know drama
within a family but it's actually really
good for the the child because their
learning helps you find wisdom elsewhere
and they're there they're going through
a rebellion period that will allow them
to get you know move on and start their
own lives and be their own successful
adults so there are these basic programs
that are underlying things but memes run
on top of that and memes can exploit the
instincts that we have I say exploit not
only the word exploit is like a bad word
but it's not necessarily a bad word
memes just take advantage of our natural
tendencies so fast food is exploiting
our instincts to eat high-calorie food
to eat food that's salty to eat food
that's sugary and so on fast food
restaurants and the marketers that work
there can exploit these instincts and
then give us the meme eat at McDonald's
eat at McDonald's is a meme eat fatty
foods eat high-calorie foods is an
instinct that we have where we're driven
towards these sorts of things because in
our ancestral past those would not have
been very abundant and so when when they
were abundant we needed to take
advantage of them so that we wouldn't
starve later on right so memes can be
designed by a marketing team to to take
advantage of our instincts but naturally
memes will just evolve on their own to
take advantage of our of our instincts
the ones that end up being really
successful in filling up the space in
the - fear are the the memes that happen
to kind of tickle our instincts
so so there's that question I asked
should memes be thought of as viruses
should memes and meme complexes so where
religion isn't as a giant meme complex
it's a whole bunch of memes working
together and it's spread from person to
person
mostly spread from parent to child
should we think of a religion as a
parasite or should we think of it as an
adaptation and last week I talked about
why I talked about the ways in which
religion does act as an adaptation I
compared myself to my brother you know I
am not religious my brother is a Mormon
and it just so happens that Mormonism
promotes as crazy as Mormonism is as as
weird as all the memes are inside
Mormonism it happens to promote all of
these things that give you a an
evolutionary advantage over your
neighbors things like you know have lots
of kids form stable families believe in
an afterlife which you know people who
believe in an afterlife are less likely
to commit suicide for example they're
people who are really just tend to have
strong communities and they can deal
with stress better this isn't always the
case but they tend to be and statistics
are pretty spectacular Mormons have on
average two times as many children as
non-religious folks
so Brett Weinstein in this debate
against Richard Dawkins he says Oh
religions and adaptation look it's doing
all the things that you would want an
organization to do to increase your
biological fitness of course religions
also cause a lot of weird stress and
problems for individuals but if you look
at the types of problems that it causes
those problems don't usually hurt an
individual's ability to reproduce there
are exceptions to this like he a
Catholic priest doesn't reproduce but
even though Catholicism makes a certain
number of its people not have kids
overall Catholics have more kids than
non-religious people even when you add
the priests into that equation so
overall religion is helping people
survive and reproduce so so is it should
we think of it as a an adaptation or is
it just is something else going on here
I would say no religion should not be
thought of as a virus like Dawkins says
it is or as an adaptation like Brett
Weinstein says it is religion should be
thought of as a symbiont and here we
have a coral and inside of its flesh our
little symbiosis in thetic symbiont
called zoos and Feli and what they do is
they photosynthesize they turn light and
carbon dioxide into sugar and they
excrete that into their hosts and zoos
and le are really interesting because
they can actually live a little bit on
their own they can spread from coral the
coral but they don't do very well on
their own and corals can actually live
for a little bit without zoos and le but
not very long they there's this mutual
dependency that they have on one another
so these are two separate evolving
entities and this is what I really want
to drive on this point
jeans are true evolving entities memes
are true evolving entities but
oftentimes they work together because
they act like symbiosis there there are
many types of symbiosis a lot of times
when we talk about symbiosis we we think
that there are you know symbiosis is
always a mutualistic relationship if you
talk to biologists study symbiosis
Latino some symbiont hold on I'm getting
ahead of myself in a row in a symbiotic
relationship the the zoo's anthalie here
they are symbiotic oral is also
considered to be a symbiotic
but when one one member of a in a
symbiotic relationship is much larger
than the other or particularly if one
lives in the side of the other we call
one the host and we call the smaller one
the Simba
but they're actually both sin my odds
but today I'm going to be talking about
hosts when I talk about a host I'll be
talking about the larger symbiont that
hosts the smaller one so there are many
types of symbiosis they're parasitic
symbiosis is when the symbiont is
actually hurting the host and this is
very common of course there's all kinds
of parasites this is a form of symbiosis
but it's parasitic symbiosis
then there's commensal istic symbiosis
this is where the symbiont is living
inside of a host or near a host
interacting with a host but doesn't
really hurt that host in any way it it
it gains something by hanging out with
the host but the host gains nothing from
it and this little critter on the right
here that I'm showing here this is a a
eyelash mite and these guys are
commenced allistic symbionts that live
on our faces most of us have these in
our eyelashes and they're little
organisms and they eat dead skin cells
they don't help us they don't hurt us
they're just hanging out and then
finally there are mutualistic forms of
symbiosis and the the zoo's anthalie
and the stony coral symbiosis is a
mutualistic symbiosis the zoo's
Antonelli help the corals survive and
reproduce and vice versa and the reason
that people who study symbiosis like to
say that there's always these three
different types of symbiosis is because
something that starts out parasitic can
evolve to be commenced allistic under
the right selection pressures and
something that is commenced allistic can
evolve to either become mutualistic or
parasitic depending on selection
pressures there are times where
something that used to be mutualistic
something that used to live in harmony
with its host might want to hurt its
host in order to survive and reproduce
and we're going to talk about that there
in a minute
among parasites there are two main types
of parasites there are obligatory
parasites so some Simba Simba odds hurt
their hosts as a normal part of their
lifecycle HIV is an example of this HIV
spreads by making the host cell rip out
rip open so HIV doesn't have to kill the
the organism that it's inhabiting but it
does have to kill this it the organism
cells and that hurts the host that
weakens the hosts ability to survive and
reproduce then there are also
opportunistic parasites so some
parasites are usually commenced allistic
or mutualistic but act as parasites
under certain circumstances so many gut
microbes will grow to numerous when
competitors are taken out with
antibiotics it's not that they've
actually evolved to hurt their hosts HIV
has evolved to hurt the host it's a it's
a very important part in HIV lifecycle
to rip open the cell that it's it's
growing in but that a lot of times
people will take antibiotics and they'll
get like an increase of yeast in their
intestines and to the point to where
they get sick and that is not like an
evolved trait necessarily that these
yeasts have it's not an essential part
of their life cycle it's just that all
their come their bacterial competitors
were taken out by these antibiotics and
they just expanded like crazy and they
started causing problems for their hosts
we call this an opportunistic parasite I
think you could break down opportunistic
parasites down even more to say that
some have literally evolved the ability
have actually evolved the ability to
become parasitic and it's a benefit to
them but only under certain
circumstances and under other
circumstances they're nice to their
hosts
so versus you know accidentally hurting
their hosts when bacteria are taken out
but there's lots of ways to look at
these and of course there's always
blurry lines with all of this there's
blurry lines between parasitic organisms
and
commence holistic organisms and
mutualistic organisms these are just
categories we try to group things into
because it helps to study them right
cholera is an extremely fascinating
symbiont it's a symbiotic lives inside
of our stomachs and we normally consider
it to be a pathogen we consider to be a
parasite but it turns out there's this
guy Pauly Wald who's been studying them
for the CDC the Center for Disease
Control and he's found that there's
actually lots of different strains of
cholera normally we think of cholera as
a disease that infects poor countries
and what will happen is it'll give its
host diarrhea so bad that they will die
and in order if you have a really nasty
strain of Cholera you have to be
drinking tons of salty liquids it
because it depletes hubiera your water
and your electrolytes and you need
usually you need to be given liquids
intervene ia's you can't drink water
fast enough you're dehydrating so
quickly that you're going to die unless
you're getting liquids infused right
into your bloodstream so it's an
extremely nasty disease if you get a
virulent strain but what's Paul you all
noticed is that there's actually lots of
benign cholera in wealthy countries
countries that are that are doing good
also have surprisingly large amounts of
people infected with cholera but the
cholera strain is being nice to its host
it's being gentle on its host people
don't even know that they're sick that
they're not sick they're just carrying
cholera and he studied the differences
the genes and the in and in these
different strains of cholera and there's
there's the sources down here on the
slide there's a ncbi paper and then
there's also a TED talk that Paul did on
you know asking can we domesticate germs
but here he learned that cholera in
countries where people are not taking
good care of their water supply they're
not filtering their water properly
cholera can spread by giving people
really bad diarrhea that gets into the
water system and then other people drink
that water and get cholera that
spreading mechanism does not work in
wealthier countries or the water is
always really well purified before it's
drinking and because of that in
countries where people have taken care
of their water supply
cholera evolves to keep the host healthy
so that the host will go to work and
hang out with friends and every time
they go to the bathroom a little bit of
Cholera you know comes out the rear end
and if you don't perfectly wash your
hands that little bit of cholera can
spread to your friends or you know when
you shake someone's hand at work and so
on so by keeping the host nice and
healthy the cholera can spread it's not
quite as fast as the parasitic version
of cholera in a poorer country but it
can still spread and survive and make a
really good living and he realized that
if we want to combat cholera when
there's an outbreak the first thing we
should do is of course help the people
that are sick
give them liquids so they don't die but
while we're doing that we need to clean
the water supply that's where we should
focus all of our time attention
attention and money and this has
revolutionized the way that we treat
cholera when there is an outbreak
absolutely wonderful research by Pauly
Wald well it turns out that memes are
exactly the same just like memes cholera
can evolve to be either parasitic to its
host or commence allistic towards its
host depending on selection pressure why
because just like means cholera is its
own evolving agent but it depends on its
host for transmission memes the ideas
that we have they depend on us for
transmission and because of that they
can actually under certain selection
pressures evolve to help us out so when
we see these religions that are so
helpful to it to their members helpful
and helping them survive and reproduce
well
that is a result of symbiosis
mutualistic symbiosis of symbiosis
so Bret Weinstein during his Dawkins
debate did not like the idea that memes
are evolving on their route he he didn't
like the idea that religions are viruses
and instead he wanted to call religions
adaptations and he's come up with this
theory about how religions evolved that
that is extremely complex I finally got
a hold of his paper and read read
through it it has to do with what he
calls lineage selection which is it's a
really messy theory that he's put
together to try to explain how it is
their religion evolves and he in general
he he basically rejects this meme idea
that memes are their own independent
evolving entities because memes he finds
are so helpful these these religious
memes that he evolved are so helpful so
he doesn't think that they're really
truly evolving as their own entities
because he thinks that if they were
evolving as their own identities they
must be parasitic and not helpful but we
always find them to be so helpful that
he's he's doubting the whole legitimacy
of means and he's made this prediction
saying that memes should show no
interest in passing themselves down when
it is not in the biological interest of
the creature whose mind it is operating
that is a prediction that he made that
is a falsifiable prediction that he made
and that prediction is absolutely false
and here isn't it as an example of memes
that I hold in my own brain that are
actually reducing my personal
evolutionary fitness dogs are better
than kids my evolutionary purpose to
reproduce is stupid it's the same
purpose that maggots and tapeworms have
and I actually got that mean by
listening to Brett he says something so
much of that and in his talks always
used birth control that's a meme that I
follow never cheat on the lady my my my
partner and I she
she doesn't want to have kids I don't
want to have kids we have dogs instead
and we always use birth control and we
don't cheat on each other so a
combination of those two things is
hurting our reproductive success right
and then finally having children is bad
for the environment
so all those memes those live in my
brain and those memes spread extremely
fast these are these are not is they're
not I'm not just a weird person for
believing these things these things are
common in our culture and all of these
names especially when they're in
combination like this they are
detrimental to the survival and reap and
not the survival but they are
detrimental to their reproduction of
their host so I am I'm losing the
evolution game because I believe these
things so memes should should show no
interest in passing themselves down when
it's not in the biological interest of
the creature whose mind it is operating
that's obviously false these memes are
super popular they're spreading like
crazy throughout our country and they
are definitely against the evolutionary
interests of their hosts now Brett seems
to believe in some sort of a group
selection he calls a lineage selection
and Adam friended was having troubles
too he seems to accept some sort of
group selection he thinks that maybe
group selection is is what's causing the
ideas that we have in our culture's to
evolve
he thinks that they're actually products
of red genes not products of memes
evolving on their own which is again
what brett weinstein thinks here is an
example of a parasitic mean that
literally spreads by hurting its host
this is a school shootings this is a
memorial kind of a makeshift memorial
that was put up after Columbine the
Columbine High School tragedy and every
time there is a school shooting like
this
the meme gets spread it's just like HIV
it depends on hurting its host in order
to spread the the people who did the
shooting in this case also died in the
process so the the meme to shoot
everybody at school died with these
people that shot everybody at school but
it also spread like crazy throughout the
country these kids I'm purposely not
showing their faces and telling you
their names because these kids got on
the cover of Time magazine for shooting
up their school they were heroes among
people who are bullied and and so on
actually there are people who will dress
up like them for Halloween still there
are girls that will go to the memorial
to worship the killers
there's also it's insane how far this
meme spread by hurting its host a meme
spread by hurting its host and also Wow
Walmart you guys are really exploiting a
tragedy they're putting up your
advertisement at a this school tragedy
brought to you by Walmart but anyway
this is a really clear example of a mean
that is absolutely destructive and
spreads by hurting its host this is
evidence that memes are symbiont
evolving independently and because of
that they can evil to become parasitic
they can evolve to become commensal
istic they can evolve to become
mutualistic so here's another list of
memes that spread that are very popular
in our culture today but are bad for
groups at every level so I mean I'm not
a group selection Asst but Brett seems
to be in here I'm giving Brett this list
just to make sure that he understands
very clearly that his prediction is
false because at every single level we
have memes that are spreading throughout
our communities that are
struck that are destructive in different
groups so on this that is destructive to
families is that kids are bad for the
environment that's gonna make families
smaller right one that's destructive to
churches all religions lead to God
that's a popular idea and a lot of
religions today and it tends to weaken
the strength of that religious community
because it's it's better for their
religion to think that only theirs is
true so they're their members keep going
to their religion political party let's
divide ourselves into smaller and
smaller competing groups this is
something that we see on the Left right
now and this is kind of a result of us
losing the presidential election and so
many people have different ideas as to
how they can they can win the next
presidential election and there's so
much division and there's people people
the left is broken up into further and
further splintering groups and that's
destructive for their ability to win
against the right in the United States
during the next election that's going to
be a really big problem for them and
then nation let's get rid of all
immigration laws because current laws
are too harsh this is another thing
that's in the United States people have
been protesting saying that we want to
end border regulation because there's
all these nasty things happening at the
border and we don't want to see these
nasty things happening at the border and
instead of changing the the laws that
exist there to make things less horrible
some people are protesting and bringing
it bringing signs saying that we need to
end border patrol in general we need to
get rid of all border laws that's a bad
idea
like a nation does need to control its
borders in order to stop itself from
getting swamped this is the same reason
that your body evolved skin to stop
organisms of all types getting inside of
you
this isn't a having borders and laws
that protect borders is extremely
important to keep a nation healthy but
we can change those laws and make them
less horrible
so anyway that then there's this global
meme that's absolutely detrimental to us
to stop other nations from bombing us
let's build thousands of nukes and point
them at all other nations this is what
America is doing right now we have a
bunch of nukes pointed at Russia and
China China's doing the same thing
Russia's doing the same thing we're all
pointing nukes at each other and that
was our solution that is the mean that
we have adopted to prevent our enemies
from bombing us and this could kill the
entire civilization it could be the end
of us so there are memes in every level
that are bad for the host I'm gonna keep
things short and just and end it there
by saying that I think that memetics the
study of memes is super important and I
really wish that more people get on
board and start doing this research the
field existed for a while there is
actually a journal online for like five
years and it died out in the the mid 90s
I think and I think the people should
pick it up again because understanding
mimetics it helps us understand why
people hold the ideas that they do and
how different ideas cooperate so it can
help us with education when if I'm an
educator and I'm frustrated because my
students aren't understanding this basic
fact that the earth is billions of years
old well if I understand the set of
memes that the 6,000 year old meme is
cooperating with I can come to
understand why it is that they believe
that and better you know change on
teaching things or I might just be like
wow I have to accept the fact as a
percentage of my students I'm just not
going to accept this fact well I can
have them memorize the fact for a test
instead and know instead of making
expecting them to accept it I can expect
them to understand it and understand why
we believe that the earth really is
billions of years old even if they don't
accept it you know those are those are
my options
understanding mimetics can help us
appreciate the contributions of religion
and other old cultural mimetic complexes
it is almost always the case in biology
though that when to symbiont have been
evolving together for a long period of
time they evolve mutualistic
relationships and the same is true with
memes and their hosts if a set of memes
has been with a group of hosts for a
long period of time it will eventually
evolve to help that host because one of
the best ways for memes to pass on is
from parent to child
and if memes they're being passed from
parent to child
don't help those children grow up and
have more kids will those mean they're
going to go extinct and because of that
because memes are symbiotic depend on
their hosts for their transmission
mimetic systems that have been around
for a long time are going to in general
act as if they are adaptations they're
going to help their hosts survive and
reproduce and then we can apply what we
know of evolution immediately to culture
this is one of the cool things that's
been happening with mimetics and if you
look at the the papers that were done
early on in memetics people are doing
that all these different things that
we're learning in disease control for
example can we can retain cholera well
we can also use that exact same
information and ask can we tame religion
or you know can we tame the school
shooting mean can we do something about
that and then finally we can use memes
as model organisms to better understand
how evolution works memes evolve away
faster than genes do and because of that
if we started using memes as model
organisms we can actually get good
information that would inform us as to
how biological systems evolve and how
diseases evolve and so on how parasites
evolve and this can that this can help
us better control diseases understand
evolution and so on so this is some
people might might think that when I
just said here circular circular
reasoning
can use evolution to understand memes
then we can use memes to understand
evolution but this is what this does is
a it's like it's like finding the it's
like doing the corner pieces of a puzzle
doing the side pieces of a puzzle the
more pieces that you have you can play
them off of each other to come to better
conclusions to find more puzzle pieces
in the future and so this is I believe
the mimetics is an extremely powerful
field potentially extremely powerful
field and people should get back into it
so that's that's my lesson for today and
I'd like to answer questions now
hello so I'm going to the live chat and
I'm gonna be looking for anything that's
orange so anyone who did at stated
clearly and gonna be looking at your
questions here so I'm getting a question
I don't really get the difference
between a meme and an idea they're
actually an idea is a meme but when we
talk about memes we're talking about
these evolving entities so an idea as it
spreads from person to person can morph
over time so Dawkins Dawkins use the
word meme it's kind of like a
combination of the word mind and gene to
really drive on the point that ideas
evolve so yes a meme is an idea that's
there they're the same thing
someone says John intelligent people
must reproduce don't leave all the
reproduction to religious fanatics well
it looks like that's the only question I
got so apparently you guys understand
this stuff really well so that's good it
was it was really frustrating talking to
Adam yesterday because I don't I still
don't know if he got it he he doesn't
understand the way in which memes really
truly act as evolving entities and I'm
curious if that's like a common thing
that other people are having that
problem too
maybe he was able to get it by the time
we were done but I'm not totally sure it
looks like he's actually in the comments
section so maybe he can say if he
understands that now I don't know but
yeah that's it for questions it looks
like so I'm just gonna go ahead and keep
this one you know a little shorter than
normal normally we go for an hour wait
for 43 minutes today but yeah I am I
think this is a lot of fun to think
about and to contemplate these things
and I would love to hear from Brett
Weinstein I'd love to have him on the
show to talk about the ways in which he
thinks that we should kind of proceed
because his his prediction has been
clearly debunked and I don't know if
that means that his overall theory is
garbage now or if it I just don't know
what he would make of this so I'd love
to hear from him on that I I don't think
his theory is totally debunked I think
that his theory of he calls a lineage
selection I would say that he's just
miss applying kin selection but I think
the kin selection really is in charge of
these kind of basic instinctual programs
that memes then exploit and memes then
take advantage of but yeah I'd love to
have him on the show to talk about him
with this again I've been I've emailed
him and have not gotten a response so if
anybody has good connections with him
let me know it'd be great to talk to him
Paul says stated casually I think it's
difficult to grasp how memes evolve
because they are not physical entities
yeah that was that was um that was Adams
big holdup
but the thing that Dawkins pointed out
is that what we need for evolution to
work being a physical object has nothing
to do with evolution being a replicator
evolution works when when a replicator
replicates and there are sometimes
modifications and those modifications
are passed on when that modified
replicator then replicates again and
when we have natural selection or
selection of some some sort so
replication plus modification plus
selection equals evolution anything that
can replicate isn't evil and do those
things as an evolving entity it is a
genuine evolving entity and Dawkins is
not is not sure about how important his
idea of mimetics is for the reason that
he thinks that maybe memes don't evolve
with enough fidelity to actually create
really complex
well evolved structures and I think that
Brett Weinstein's observation that
religions usually do cause people to do
really good at surviving and reproducing
I think that Brett Weinstein's
observation of this is proof that memes
really are evolving entities that do
evolve with enough fidelity to produce
really complex sophisticated structures
a religion is a really complex
sophisticated structure that allows its
members to survive and reproduce and it
does so in ways that are so weird so
bizarre that we have to study it to
realize how its
doing it how is it that Mormons are so
successful at breeding compared to other
groups why what is it about Mormonism
that's so successful and it turns out
the things that make Mormonism
successful are weird its beliefs weird
beliefs about God
weird beliefs about the family unit
really weird like completely false
beliefs but those completely false
beliefs happen to make you really good
at surviving and reproducing and having
strong families so that your kids
survive and reproduce as well and the
fact that these complex highly complex
religious structures have evolved is
evidence that memes really are evolving
in a level that is significant and in a
way that really is producing legitimate
adaptations for these meme complexes I
think the problem with understanding
these things that we generally think of
evolution is a sort of conscious process
which is which it is not yes and and
this is this is extra confusing with
memes because memes are ideas and we
think of ideas with our consciousness
right but it's it's it's when these
ideas start to spread that it's not it's
not really happening so much at a
conscious level right nobody wants to
spread the school shooting meme right
nobody wants to do that yet Time
magazine they've put this school
shooters on its cover it and it if you
look online you'll find our news
articles that have the school shooters
face all the people that they killed
stats about how many they individually
killed stats about which weapons they
used it's like baseball cards for for
murderers and it's we are promoting this
and we're doing it on accident we're
doing it because this meme this meme has
just it's evolved to just get our brains
in such a weird way that we can't help
it sharing it I mean I'm sharing it
right now and consciously by the way
avoided using their names and faces in
this presentation because I think that's
one
the mean spreads even further but the
that is a confusion people think that
others consciousness but evolution isn't
a conscious process therefore memes
can't be evolving through an
evolutionary process but the memes
really do they just they they are
replicators and they are evolving in
ways that we do not understand because
we don't study them and we should
understand them so whoa I just lost
someone says is a destructive cult a
meme parasite whenever kind of it acts
more virus like so cults here's
something really interesting that we
know from studying diseases when it when
a when a symbiotic force comes in
contact with a host usually its
destructive to that host and the reason
for that is there's there's more ways to
to hurt a host than to help a host and
so when the symbiont is new it's usually
acting like a parasite and this is the
same with religions when religions are
new they're usually acting like
parasites
now religions most most new religions
aren't really all that new most of their
ideas are super old and so they've
already a lot of religions out of the
gate are helpful to their their their
members if they're not dramatically
different than other religions that are
they exist but a cult is as a new
religion that is significantly different
from other religions and they often
start out very parasitic because they're
so new they're like I said there's more
ways to hurt a host than to help a host
an example of this in biologies HIV is
super destructive to humans but that
same disease doesn't hurt chimps at all
chimps carry SIV they carry a version of
HIV and that's where we think that we
got HIV from originally is from eating
chimpanzees so people who are hunting
them cutting themselves while cleaning
the meat got HIV from chimps but the HIV
does not hurt chimps it's been evolving
with chimps
thousands and thousands and thousands of
generations and it's evolved towards a
benign I don't know that it's
mutualistic I don't know that HIV helps
him but it's it well I guess it helps
scare people from killing them but it's
it's a benign disease for most chimps
that doesn't bother him for us it kills
us because it's it's so new but with
time HIV the we suspect that with time
even if it had never been treated HIV
would eventually evolved towards benign
Ness and humans as well we carry all
sorts of diseases that are benign to us
and you actually when we had the when
when Europeans made contact with the
Native Americans here we had tons of
diseases that we brought with us there
weren't a big deal and we when Native
Americans got those diseases that killed
them because it hadn't been evolving
with them for very long their genes were
different enough that the disease's we
were carrying and we'd already developed
commenced allistic relationships with
we're hurting their new hosts and so
that's a huge problem let's see
if anything from the way
potatoes two political views are
considered memes what aspects of them do
you think we should study is it the meta
aspect of how they evolve well I think
we should study all sorts of things I
mean that studying the way that that
people peel potatoes is actually pretty
cool because it's super benign no one's
gonna get offended by a study on how we
peel potatoes some people might you know
be okay with us doing a massive invasive
study on how you peel potatoes we might
be so we might be less willing to let
people study how you know study our sex
lives and so on but the I think that as
mentioned studying how it is that memes
are transmitted how it is that they
evolve and how it is that they evolved
from being parasitic to benign is really
important by the way the peeling potato
meme seems totally benign right you
could never kill somebody that meme
could never cause the death of anybody
right well turns out that the pioneers
were actually dying because they were
peeling their potatoes
actually they were dying mainly because
the the meme that they they had accepted
this meme that potatoes were for poor
people
so when pioneers were getting ready to
go across the plains they would buy
supplies and what was available to them
was wheat salted meats and potatoes and
a handful of other vegetables and stuff
a lot of people were ignoring potatoes
and going for wheat because potatoes
were seen as like poor people food and
those that did buy potatoes got some
potatoes to bring with them they would
usually peel them before eating them it
turns out that a lot of people who got
stuck because of bad weather had to set
up camps in certain areas that were not
colonized yet they could only just eat
off their stores that they brought with
them and those that did they did not
bring potatoes and those that were
peeling potatoes oftentimes got scurvy
and sometimes they would die so the
Chilean potatoes before eating them mean
actually turn
to be deadly in some cases just because
there's less vitamins and the potato
than there are in the skin that's not
totally true there's lots of vitamins in
the potato as well but and there
wheat has no vitamin C in it so people
are getting scurvy if they were just
eating wheat so the weirdest things will
will turn out to be detrimental
so I guess science is a positive meme
science is a positive meme unless we
invent something that kills us all with
it then yeah maybe but maybe it turned
out to be a bad mean I've always
wondered about the evolution of ideas
when it comes to alternative medicine
how nonsense medicine came to grow and
still be so prevalent in cultures I was
just talking to a doctor about this
yesterday so my girlfriend is a nurse
and her brother is a doctor so we were
we were literally talking about this
last night and it's really funny cuz
what happens when he cannot treat a
patient when a patient has a disease and
he knows there's no treatment for it
like he's he knows what the treatments
are for diseases he knows what works and
what does not and a lot of times he'll
get patients and they'll say yeah you
have you have this disease it's
incurable
and you have between this and this
amount of time to live and that's it the
doctor will just tell you to your face
that's an untreatable disease well a lot
of these times that people will go home
and be like screw this I'm not dying I'm
gonna find a cure and there's a million
people out there willing to say oh yeah
modern medicine is not nearly as
efficient as alternative medicine so
that's that's one of the reasons that's
alternative medicines not all
alternative medicine is bad a lot of it
is bad for just one quick example in
Oregon people who do alternative
medicine one of their main diagnostic
tools that they use is a diet
they'll put you on a super plain diet
and then start slowly adding things to
see if it makes you just
if something in your diet was making you
sick this is something that doctors in
Oregon weren't doing but naturopathic
doctors were and naturopathic doctors
had a bunch of success in identifying
allergies that way and so now it's
actually something that mainstream
medicine is doing too but so that there
are there are cases where naturopathic
doctors or alternative medicine ideas
will end up being successful and that
will get marketed by these naturopathic
doctors there are also cases where
mainstream medicine will do something
horrible so the the painkiller epidemic
in the United States it's killing lots
of people that is something that is
mainstream medicines fault and the
really weird thing about this is that
when mainstream medicine does something
bad like causes this epidemic of the
opioid crisis they get blamed for it and
everybody knows it's their fault but
when a naturopathic doctor does
something crazy and kills a bunch of
kids or you know whatever it's that
doctor gets blamed for it
and that website gets blamed for it not
naturopathic medicine in general so
there's a really weird by being the
outsider
you can always dodge the the negative
news about other outsiders like you
because oh well they're not they're not
Outsiders in the same way that I am but
if you are the mainstream you can't
dodge those those tragedies you always
get blamed for them that's that's one of
the reasons that I think the alternative
medicine meme is so prevalent I don't
see
it feels like memes encompass so many
different kinds of ideas and behaviors a
lot of them are already studied by
fields like psychology sociology
religious studies and so on yes
that is true and actually that's that's
one of the reasons and I think mimetics
didn't take off really well it's because
oh there's a couple of problems with
mimetics that have to be worked out
before it really sticks and one is how
is it that we parse out individual memes
from each other in in religious studies
we talk about doctrines as you know an
individual doctrine like Jesus Christ
rose from the dead
that's a doctrine that most Christian
religions believe some might not theirs
well actually I don't know of any
Christian religions that don't jordan
peterson doesn't seem to think that
Jesus actually rose from the dead but he
still calls himself a Christian there's
so people have been following different
doctrines throughout history because a
lot of doctrines so the doctor in a
virgin birth of a deity that's a
doctrine that predates Christianity it's
super super ancient and so people have
been following memes across time but the
study of mimetics really isn't so much
about naming changing the name of an
idea to I mean like that's not what is
all about it's the study of mathematics
is about studying how it is that ideas
evolve and how it is that they evolve
symbiosis mutualistic symbiosis with
other ideas and mutualistic symbiosis
with their hosts or parasitic
interactions with their hosts this is
what the study of emetics is all about
and the study mimetics has has gotten
kind of kicked back from other fields of
research because Dawkins has been so
adamant about calling religions viruses
and just insisting that they are viruses
well he's insistent that they are
viruses that that makes anyone think
well religions are parasites when you
say that they're viruses you're
what you're saying is that they are
parasites and it's super obvious to
anyone that studies culture that
religions aren't best described as
parasites on the evolutionary fitness of
their tenants religions are better
described as adaptations right as as
Brett Weinstein has observed but the
reason Dawkins has only seen them as
parasites in the past is because Dawkins
hates the way that religion interacts
with science so really when he was
saying that religion is parasitic humans
it's parasitic on science it's it's
parasitic - instead of memes that he
holds dear and that's that's why he is
so upset with religion and I share his
frustration on that aspect but he is he
is wrong if he thinks that religions are
bad for their survival and reproduction
of the people that I really just because
they certainly are good statistically at
least in the past they have shown to be
good let's see crashing thunder
question but I just want to say I
appreciate these weekly Sunday morning
discussions lectures much more
insightful in church all right that is
difficult that's a difficult question
depends on what you mean by Jordan
Peterson he's trolling there yeah
Jordan Peterson has been criticized for
using common words in special new ways
without telling his audience that he's
using him in special new ways that is
very problematic for a communicator and
that's actually a reason for much like a
lot of the people that hate Jordan
Peterson hate him because they
misunderstand him and they misunderstand
because he's using words unwisely and
you know he acts like he's a victim and
of hatred from the public but a lot of
it is his own fault his word choice but
anyway that's another conversation for
another day let's see a person I met
recently mentioned non-authoritative
Christianity even the story of
Resurrection he stated didn't have to be
true for him to believe in God okay yeah
of someone someone says made me dr.
Dawkins is just predicating the dead end
of this adaptation by religious world
war like like dodo 1 egg an app tation
because as old as religion is it is just
a secondary and evolutionary time scale
yeah well um I think it I think it is
important to start making the case now
that if we keep on believing in religion
the way that we have in the past it
could really cause Armageddon because in
the past you know we're fighting each
other with Spears and sticks now we have
nuclear weapons and so the the divisive
miss that religion causes between
different groups really could be the end
of our civilization when that's combined
with the technology given to us by
science so it could be that science and
religion combined forces joined forces
to eradicate the human population that
would be horrible
okay let's see oh I want Paul last week
kept asking a question apologia or not
really actually question making a
comment that he wanted me to comment on
and Richard Dawkins The Selfish Gene he
defines a gene as gosh I better pull up
the slides so that I don't screw this up
he has a very specific definition for
gene and it's different than the
definition we use for gene today Richard
Dawkins defined a gene in his book as a
stretch of genetic material that
survives three large number of
successive individual bodies that's how
we define a gene and Paul asked isn't
that how we define an allele now so
shouldn't the selfish gene be the
selfish allele and yes Paul you are
correct that is more or less what we
call an allele today today the word gene
is synonymous with with the older word
called sister on a sister on is a
stretch of DNA that ends up being coded
for well that ends up summoning RNA
polymerase to create a chain of RNA
that's what what we typically call it
gene and some biologists only consider a
stretch of DNA to be a gene if it ends
up coding for a protein others are okay
with if it just codes or if it just acts
as a template for a strand of RNA so
there's a yeah confusion in what a gene
is but yeah Richard Dawkins definition
of a gene is the modern definition of an
allele so you are correct Paul and I
finally redeemed myself by answering
your question hopefully even though I
see that you're not here in the comments
today Shannon is still Talia I know some
says I don't like how militant Dawkins
is I think we need to be tolerant if we
expect tolerance from religious people
yeah so actually the reason that I
started stated clearly my other channel
is because I wanted to do my my friends
and neighbors when I was living in
Tennessee they were all Southern
Baptists and they didn't they hated
evolution and I wanted to teach
evolution to them and they weren't
really willing to read textbooks because
they're too long technical and so I
there's all the stuff by Dawkins that
was online and there's his books are
great and I wanted to share them with my
friends but Dawkins work tends to be
peppered with little insults towards
Christianity and I knew that they
wouldn't keep listening if they're being
insulted in the middle of this lesson on
biology so that was actually one of the
reasons I decided I need to create my
own materials my own teaching materials
and that's one of the reasons I started
stated clearly it's because of it
Dawkins isn't the only one who does
there's a lot of people who are really
good at teaching evolution like to
insult religion a lot while they do it
and that can be problematic let's see
okay I think that answers questions I
was fun so long for now until next week
stay curious